hello Pakistan has released the Indian
pilot it took captive in what it's
calling a gesture of peace
Wing Commander urban and an ottoman
walked back across the wire Hatari
border after being shot down on
Wednesday in the disputed Kashmir region
Pakistani officials say they handed him
over to India in a bid to ease the
tensions between the two nations one of
you one of us all Indians are happy to
have impact so was he
and he comes back into his own country
you can I think he was too overwhelmed
by emotion but the happiness in his eyes
also here ramen ramen is live for us in
New Delhi so hail relief for all over
India right now at his release yes
certainly it's been much anticipated
certainly for the last 48 hours that
Wing Commander a BN that would actually
be released but when was the actual
question we've been waiting for about
six hours for more news about his
transfer and those very few what 10 20
steps across the border from Pakistan
into India it was delayed several times
they even up to the last minute but as
you saw from those pictures he was
slowly escorted to the border by the
lady that you can see the traditional
shalwar kameez accompanying him is from
the ministry of foreign affairs and
standing next to her the gentleman in
the Air Force uniform is a
representative of course from the the
Air Force they escorted him to the
Rangers who are the basically the
commandos who look after the border on
the Pakistan side and there he was then
I saw handed over to the Indians he
would have been brought across as he was
quite late on to be processed at the
wire border and there it was assumed
that he would be put in charge or
certainly seen by the Red Cross neutral
body who would have made sure that he
was medically
fit and also he was the man that the
Indians were looking for and then they
would then escort him across the border
and hand him over to Indian officials of
course he was taken into the care of the
Indian Air Force and it's assumed he
will now head towards New Delhi for a
complete medical check-up at a
debriefing and Sohail this this these
ongoing tensions between the latest
ongoing tensions between India and
Pakistan it all began of course more
than two weeks ago with that attack in
in Paloma and indian-administered
Kashmir on on the Indian and
paramilitary forces does this release
now do something to to ease those
tensions a little bit
well this has been the question to a
certain extent that Pakistan would like
we've heard of phrases from the
Pakistani Prime Minister this is a
gesture of goodwill an opportunity to
ease tensions certainly from the Indian
side there has been a reserved silence
until their wing commander was returned
both the Ministry of External Affairs as
well as the Defense Ministry were
keeping very quiet about exactly what
they were or were not going to say there
is a great deal of tension here
politically as well about what's gone on
there is a ongoing spat between the
opposition and the incoming and
incumbent government about how
politicized this particular incident has
become but regardless of that the
tension between India and Pakistan has
continued there was an ongoing curfew in
Kashmir and even on Friday there were
skirmishes in Handwara small area in
northern Kashmir where two armed gunmen
were fighting Indian forces and at the
you might say the end of the day what
the news we have there is that six
security personnel have been killed one
civilian and several others injured and
even those details at the moment are a
little bit sketchy we try to get more
information on that and even on Thursday
we saw shelling between India and
Pakistan in the Kashmir region with one
fatality a lady that was buried in punch
so the tension continues as does the
pressure on both countries both
domestically and internationally to try
and find a solution to ease the tension
but it's certainly not over all right
for the moment to hell Raman life was
there in New Delhi thanks will